on today's show we talk about adult
themes so watch out for the little ears
in the room
and for god's sake do not listen to this
with your in-laws
okay we're gonna be talking about
preparing for deployment
as a family we're gonna be talking about
intimate dreams that
we don't wanna have we're going to be
talking about friendship
and what happens when you're in your 30s
and 40s and you realize i don't have any
friends
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show thanks for hanging out
hope you're doing well hope you're
staying well hope you're being kind
we're so glad that you're here you want
to talk about your relationships your
friends your mental health your work
whatever's going on in your life
give me a shout one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
it's one eight four four six nine three
three two nine one hey that just reminds
me do we even say one anymore
or do we just say eight four four
yeah i stumped the zero one kid because
last time i told everybody to do www
and y'all looked at me like i got here
in a covered wagon
yeah the one at the beginning of phone
numbers is the equivalent of the www
you're right man i'm getting so old this
is ridiculous
all right so hey this morning i was
doing um some media hits
and where you get all gussied up and
then you
have a camera pointed at you and then
just various morning news stations
throughout the country
roll through and you answer a couple of
questions about whatever you want to
talk about
and i was talking to an awesome guy his
name is derek he is the host of a
morning show in charlotte
and one of the questions came up was
about anxiety
and kids going back to school and that
got me thinking
i've i think i've said this on this show
and i've said it on other shows another
podcast
please put this in your in your back
pocket in your front pocket and in the
front of your head and in your soul
i hear so many parents talking about oh
my goodness kids are finally going back
to school after spring break right
schools are starting to open up across
the country they've been open for a
month or two months they're opening back
up
workplaces are slowly starting to open
back up and i'm hearing this phrase a
lot
i can't wait till things get back to
normal i'm so excited my kid's gonna go
to school
i can't wait to get back in the office
things are going to be back to normal
there is
no going back there's no
business as usual everything moving
forward is going to be
new so here's what i want you to do when
your kids
go back to school it's going to be
really exciting at first
there's going to be a big drop off and
then things are going to get
hard when you go back to the office it's
going to be
weird and there's going to be that guy
in the corner there's going to be the
person who just wants to hug everybody
and you're like i'm pretty sure you're
super spreader right there's going to be
the masked people and the not mass
people and the
anger people and the vax police and the
non-ve
give everybody grace assume that people
are doing the best they can what they
have
and if you got kids go back to school be
hyper
hyper intentional about plugging in with
them hyper intentional about talking
when you on the way to school
talking on the way home and i don't care
if they're 15 17
or 6. this is going to be hard this is
going to be
weird i want you to be connected with
boundaries what does that mean that
means man if my my 17 year old got home
i was like dad i've been stuck in my
house for a year
everybody's getting together for a party
if i wouldn't have let him go to this
thing before kova don't let him go now
right don't compound
a mistake man you get all a year's worth
of pent up like
i just remember being stuck in my house
for a few weeks
what we ended up doing as kids can't
imagine
right what it would be like to be stuck
wrapped up inside a home for a
year and then let out in the wild right
it's gonna be release the hound so make
sure your kid's connecting with you make
sure you're connecting with your partner
make sure you're talking to your kids
make sure they're connecting with their
friends and make sure you got boundaries
too
right there is no old life it's over
you want to you want to come up with a
program to torture children
lock them in their house for a year with
no friends and make them stare at a
screen
i mean that's it's we did what we had to
do and now we're starting to open it
back up
life is going to be new we got to do new
things just just get that
out of your head and focus on building
something new right moving forward
all right we got a packed show and we
got a wild show today
so let's get right to the phones let's
go to melinda in san antonio
tejas what's up melinda hey dr dalony
how are you excited i'm doing good i'm
excited to talk to you i'm excited to
talk to you and by the way i just was
like
hey what's up i don't know i'm yelling
like we're just having a conversation on
the phone i just went and made it all
weird
so sorry about that so what's up how's
it going it's going really good i
wanted to ask how to mentally prepare
our family for my husband's upcoming
deployment
is this his first one a second second
one okay so tell me about the first one
so the first one um it was a nine-day
notice but we kind of ripped the
band-aid
early on yeah how long was it gone
for about seven and a half months nine
days and seven and a half months
yeah whoa that is slap it up flip it
reverse it dude that's
quick so then so y'all got through it i
guess right
we did we did we did get through it we
um
we came out of our marriage a lot
stronger okay our kids at the time
um but we're about one and three-ish
oh my gosh so they i mean
they didn't know any better so it was
kind of like thinking back now it was
kind of easy um
now fast forward they're five and seven
so now it's
you know they're more attached so that's
why i'm
kind of like wanting to seek more advice
on how to go around at this
go around yeah for sure okay so you got
a five and a seven year
old how long have y'all been married uh
we've been married
for going on seven and together for 11.
okay uh dude island's in the stream
that's what y'all are dude that's
awesome seven and eleven very cool and
then
hey what did you learn last time that
helped
improve your marriage communication
what does that mean um that means
if i'm having a hard time i kind of need
him to be my ear
okay you know through the good and the
bad
um and on his side
he kind of like puts like i don't know
he
there's a boundary like he can tell me
about all the work stuff but at the same
time i can't understand
all that he's going through right yeah
and that
that's one of the most common things i
hear from
couples and especially from the person
who's deployed
is how do i stay present in my
relationship at home
and not let them know what's actually
going on here
and not let them know hey we were you
know drove over an iud today
and not fill in the blank right and be
fully present there
but all yeah it just becomes really
tricky and how do you
as mom get to have a bad day when you
know he's over there
doing god knows what right so it's that
mess man so what are some tricks you
guys learned
to communicate better
um i guess just
uh making time you know when the kids
are asleep or
you know being on opposite schedules
making that
time whether it's super early for him or
it's super late for me like making time
that we can actually
you know just have a conversation
whether it's like just
can just talk like we would regularly
but outside of all
the background like our situation or
whatnot um
yeah i think that would be so when when
does he leave
uh sometime this summer okay so you've
got a few months to plan for this
are you gonna have time to do a vacation
together do something fun together or is
it gonna be work work work and then
we're out of here
we've been taking vacations um so
this deployment we've known it for about
nine months ahead of time
that's like good and bad we're able to
plan it better but it's bad in the sense
it's kind of like dragging and
getting dreadful yeah and it keeps going
and going
so what do your kids think about this
we haven't told them yet what
yeah we don't melinda
we just don't want to drag it for them
either okay so we were thinking like
two three months before he actually does
you know deploy
to go ahead and let them know that this
is what's going to be happening
okay your heart and his heart are in the
right place
and it is but it's out in the yard okay
so you want to give them time to
digest this internalize this and norm
this
okay and there's several ways you guys
can do this as a couple
um and there's some really cool ways
y'all can do this as a couple
here's the thing they're gonna miss
their dad you're gonna miss their
your husband y'all's family unit is
gonna have a big gaping hole in it
right and the band-aid thing
can kind of work for grown-ups because
you guys have multiple frames of
references
this is their world and giving them some
heads up in ways that they can see and
feel and understand
really makes a difference it turns it
into a hard time
it switches it from it being a hard time
to trauma
okay okay dad disappearing
after a nine-day notice or a two-week
notice is
a like that's a an explosion in a
child's mind
dad going through some things and we
know this is going to happen and here's
the day and here's when this happens
that is something they can digest in
little pieces okay so here's a couple
things that i would recommend you all do
that can be a lot of fun it'll be hard
but it'll be a lot of fun
okay okay um first thing is
is i would get on amazon or i would have
your husband check around
base there's going to be some children's
literature
about mom or dad deploying
and what we want to do is we want to not
leave what deployment looks like to your
kids imagination we want to paint that
in as clear a picture as possible
reading stories to kids where they see
themselves they see daddy they see mommy
is a beautiful way to let the kids
digest it in a way that
they can you know through a cartoon
right um so i'd get online and see if
you can buy some books and then just
make reading at night a part of your
rhythm moving forward
do you all do that anyway we do okay
awesome so this is just some new
literature you can
you can introduce this weekend you can
get on amazon today and order it and
they'll be here by the weekend and you
can start them
the second thing is is begin and
hopefully this doesn't sound cheesy but
i want this to become part of your
rhythm so that when they go it's a part
of their rhythm
begin a weekly hey we're gonna make a
thing for dad
you and the kids and have your husband
do a weekly
i'm gonna make something for the kids
and then y'all can exchange them
in person and i want you and him to
do the best you can to make this
really grand gestures wow this is so
awesome big hugs big music swells like
the whole thing right
and it can be funny cards and silly
cards and
a weird art project with hair and grass
whatever kids are up you know the
kids are doing stuff but i want them to
get a picture of what it looks like when
dad opens this or that
because then when they do these things
and they s and you mail them to them
or you have a weekly skype call with the
kids and your husband
overseas they're going to be able to
remember that and have a touch point to
it right and so it's going to become
part of this rhythm that you can
continue when he's overseas
another thing you may want to do is once
a week have him call them on
on facetime on skype they can get used
to that conversation
that way of talking and it can be silly
and fun they can come up with a game
that they're going to do
naturally and then when he goes overseas
and you do a
weekly call with the kids and you get
everybody on
then again they they're able to have
some touch point feelings we remember
that when dad was inside and he was in
the garage and now he's overseas and
this is pretty cool and
it's not going to be easy it's going to
be fun and here's one last thing i would
recommend
see if your husband would be willing to
do little bits of
pt with them little bits of training
little bits of hey we're gonna
dress up and so that they can have a
mental picture of what's dad's day like
when he's
overseas is he jogging and working out
is he having to do push-ups and sit-ups
and the kids can climb all over him
does he have to do jiu-jitsu practice
does he have to stand at attention
really tall does he have to do some of
those things
and again all we're trying to do is to
connect pictures to their reality
right and then when he goes overseas it
can be hard yes is it going to be so sad
yes i'm going to be tears and hugs yes
but man they are not going to have to
invent what his life looks like because
they'll have some pictures of what
that's going to look like
and give them time to process this
um do you guys do things together y'all
have meals together
regularly uh breakfast and dinner we try
to um
really have together as a family i love
love that
so one thing that i would introduce
and you may already do this do you all
do some sort of best and worst or
the hardest laugh of the day or your
favorite thing of the day
no we don't so start that tonight
hey new thing kids we're doing a new
thing in our house what's your bmws
what's the best thing
what's the worst thing that happened
what's the hardest thing what's the
funniest thing
and begin to introduce some of those
things so that when you're having to
text to your husband
the next morning if the kids have to go
to bed and they don't get to see him or
talk to him or text with him
you could say hey i got dad's bmws from
last night again another touch point
so as you hear me saying that
does that sound doable or are you still
kind of freaked out that they're going
to know so far in advance
that that kind of puts it in a different
perspective i know
i love these ideas especially the little
pt training i think
the both kids would love because they
always want to go to work with them
okay and so i think that one in the bmw
you know it would it just would spark
more conversation
between us so you are a mom that had to
hold it together with a one and a
three-year-old
i don't know how you did that that's
pretty impressive and you said our
marriage even your marriage even got
better
tell me what's going on in your heart
and mind during this transition
um nervous super super nervous
um i'm currently
i don't know i'm getting emotional just
maybe thinking about it you're getting
emotional because your husband's about
to go overseas that's okay
um i'm currently full time in nursing
school as well okay
so i'll be in my last year and so just
trying to like balance it out making
sure the kids know i'm present
yeah even though i'm you know my
schedule's gonna be
crazy um
so kelly gave me a heads up before this
call
and i wanted to make sure i talked to
somebody who's got some actual
experience with this so i actually
called
my good buddy john who is a an active
navy seal
and said hey what would you recommend
what would you and your wife recommend
because they've been through this
they've got kids
and the first thing you said you know
what he said was make sure
she has a gang
a group of people not even in the
military
sometimes that can be toxic right and
where everyone just talks and it kind of
gets gossipy it may be you may have a
great
circle of military wives but i want you
to start cultivating
people that will be in your corner on
those hard days and those exhausting
days when on final exam and midterm days
on rotation days that
they will be able to show up when you
text them and say hey can somebody help
with dinner and there will be no
questions asked they're just going to be
your ride or die for the next year
and if you take out a group of friends
you've got a couple of friends like that
now
like just yeah i knew you would you
sound awesome
if you have those folks and you take
them out and say hey i'm starting to get
a little bit
because my husband's gonna leave again
in a few months
i want to be able to count on you and
i'll pay for pizza and beer sometimes
but there's gonna be nights i text you
and call you and i want you guys i want
you to have this conversation over a
meal i want them to feel special
and i want you to let them know how
important they are to you and make it a
moment
and let them know what they mean to you
and then say there's gonna be nights and
i'm gonna call you
we just go pick up some kind of garbage
food for us to get us through the night
and they will be empowered and feel
awesome and feel good
and it's going to give them some purpose
somebody to support and love and care on
while you're going through what you're
going through and
i know you did this last time don't
forget to
to stay in connection communication with
your husband
always always i want to take a moment to
honor the service
men and women who go overseas and i
always want to take a moment
and honor the service men and women
spouses girlfriends boyfriends who are
staying at home
raising kids trying to get through
school holding down
life um that is a tough tough gig
melinda i'm so grateful for you
thank you thank you thank you for your
call thank you for your service
let me know how those conversations go
with your kids
and let us know how that works out it
will be a blessing and a gift to other
families in your same situation so
thanks for a call
all right let's go to joseph in
cleveland ohio
what's up brother joseph how are we
doing good how you doing dr john
you know what i was going to come up
with something clever i don't have a
clever thing so i'll say i'm doing
pretty good man
i mean sometimes you just jump and then
there's no water in the pool that's just
what happened right then
so what's up man i feel that um i i feel
that
awesome i can already tell it's gonna be
a fun call so what's up
um i've been having some really
really reoccurring annoying dreams
regarding
myself and my mother-in-law okay um
more of an intimate personal
relationship
kind of dream you know yeah awkward
makes it awkward you know
i can i'm not going to imagine it but
i'll take your word for it how about
that
yeah yes that works um
it's gotten so like frequent
that the point that like even when i'm
trying
to like you know not be there mentally
in
when i'm awake and around my family and
it's just frustrating because it's like
i've talked with my wife about it she's
cool because it's like
it's a dream it's not like you're doing
anything no hey hold on
all things just stopped every digital
like zero and one just stopped turning
just now
you told your wife about this how'd that
go
it was awkward but my once i had the
kind of relationship
hey listen that may be the
understatement of planet earth
like i i mean it was awkward
yeah i know i know this is nothing for
me
because like
her mom is one of those people that like
her friends in high school would make
comments to her about her mom so it's
like
she's beautiful he has grown up yes okay
and so
your your wife has had to deal with this
forever right yes
okay and i wasn't weird when i said
anything to my wife about it like she
completely understood she's like you're
not the first guy to
have a dream and it just so happens to
be like
about my mom hey hold on like
you're being for real that's a real
conversation you all had yeah and she
was just like cool man
she was like hey it's it's just a dream
you can't control what you dream about
as frustrating as it is as
real as it is it's not real but like
listen i don't know what you've been i
don't know what you did in another life
but you married so well every day of
your life you should get down on both
knees and just be like
thanks man yep and she
like my wife is an angel on earth and
she's
yeah 37 weeks pregnant and she's 37
weeks pregnant
yes sir wow okay so
um man we're not even talking about the
dream i just can't even believe
one you're brave and you're like one of
the core principles of the show man is
the secrets destroy relationships and
right when you told me that i thought oh
my gosh man just the
tension that would be in your home you
had enough courage to say that
and you may have had enough courage to
say that because
um sounds like your wife is a just a
really remarkable human being
so um when you say recurring they're
happening how often are these dreams
happening
probably once every other week okay and
how often
are you in proximity to your
mother-in-law
pretty frequent like we go to the same
church we have dinner with them at least
once a week like
we're very close to my wife's parents
okay
and so it keeps happening
and you're now starting to feel awkward
in
the real world yeah because like i'm
i'm about to be a dad to a daughter and
i am just like
it's awkward for my own mental space
because my brain is just like
oh hey remember that dream that happened
last night and i'm like i would really
like to not think about that over
thanksgiving dinner
right now thank you yep
everyone in the united states just
nodded their head and they were like
yeah i could pretty much see that
yeah we're all with you on this one
joseph all right
so is this dream a replay
is it essentially the same um
narrative every time is it different
don't get gratuitous man i i don't want
that stuff in my mind
but why don't you walk me through
different scenarios same end result okay
all right
so here's the thing good for you
and your wife sex dreams are almost
never about sex they are
intimate dreams are almost never about
intimacy they're about
i mean they can be about a million
different things but they're often about
being accepted
being deemed worthy being deemed up to
you know
that you've got a valued place here
and so what is your relationship like
with your mother-in-law
fantastic okay like she has
said she's made comments to my life that
she thinks of me like her own kid
um we're very close and like she talks
to me and my wife a lot about stuff
going on in her own personal life and
not
nothing like too in detail just like
she talks with us and we have open
conversations and it's
yeah so there's no hierarchy there's no
rule you're not walking around
feeling like uh i'm not i didn't i
didn't
she's disappointed in who you her
daughter married
everybody's rocking and rolling and
feeling great about life
yeah okay so here's two things one
i'm not a psychologist and psychologists
spend time
interpreting dreams and most people will
tell you dream interpretation is
voodoo right it's got some reality but
usually it's the reality is what how it
makes you feel so that's my question to
you
are you carrying shame around about this
are you annoyed by it are you frustrated
about it
um do you like it like what's going on
in your heart in your head here
d all of the above okay that's
the best way that i can answer that um
like everything that i love about my
wife it's she got from her mom
okay um but she's not your mom
no no she's not her mom yeah that's what
i meant yeah
yeah i get that and it's like
it's just unfortunate that like the
person that i am married to
has all these great qualities that her
mom also has and it's just like
it's not unfortunate yeah i was like say
why is that a fortune it sounds awesome
hold on it it's fantastic because
they're great people it's just
i don't want that image of my
mother-in-law
you know okay so do you want to
stop that dream yes
okay so i'm gonna i know
one thing that is from the the nightmare
research
it's from dr joyner and he's an
extraordinary researcher suicide
researcher
but um he walks through
a really a clear step-by-step path on
how to deal with nightmares and this
isn't a nightmare this may not work this
is the best i've got
and what i would tell you is in short
order if this doesn't work
you need to go see somebody a
psychologist
probably not a therapist probably a
psychologist who is going to
walk you through other things about this
dream here's the challenge for you
as i think you like having this dream
you don't like what it means for you in
the real world is that fair
yeah that's fair and as long as you like
having that dream
man it's gonna recur and it's gonna
occur especially if there's no power
dynamic
you're going to have to make a decision
that i don't want this in my head
anymore
okay i honestly i don't think you're
there yet
i think you're more freaked out by it's
kind of weird and
it's not super common you're probably
gonna call your buddies and be like
dudes guess what you're not gonna do
that
and right so it's more you feel like a
freak
but you like it and until you decide i
don't want this
man it's gonna keep looping back on you
but here's here's the rundown okay
um you have to re-script this as the way
dr joyner calls it he had to rescript
this
in writing okay so you have to write out
the scenario
and then you have to write out an
alternative ending
so let's say you are um
i don't know you come home to your house
and your mother-in-law's there and
there's nobody else
there and every time you have this dream
it always ends with a certain outcome
right
you're going to rescript this you're
going to see that your mother-in-law is
there you're going to choose to get back
in your car and you're going to leave
and then you're going to go somewhere
else and then when you get home your
mother-in-law's not going to be there
anymore she's not she's going to quit
showing up
and then throughout the day after you
have written this down
you have to run this narrative through
your head multiple times you have to
practice it on a regular basis
okay he would say you have to retell the
new version of the dream throughout the
day okay and
what it does it it resets your mind it
it creates a new path for this dream to
head down once
that ball gets pushed down the hill
does that make sense yeah
tell me if i'm crazy i don't think
you're gonna do that
like do the writing things out
it sounds fantastic and i would love to
not have this dream anymore
i really would really yeah
okay i mean i get hey i'm fundamentally
a guy and it's like
i know biologically great whoopty do but
like
mentally and where i want to be with my
wife
like because we want to be pastors and
like i don't want any
crap holding me down you know yes i do
um my guess is there's other things here
that we can't handle on a show
have you been to counseling recently no
why do you laugh at that no it's
i sorry we're working through uh dave
ramsey's baby steps right now and it's
not in the budget for counseling and
stuff so here's what also is not in the
budget divorce
here's what also is not in the budget an
absolute
train wreck
between your mother-in-law and you and a
new baby girl
and all of the derivative mess that's
gonna happen
okay you don't have money not to do
this
but my guess is you've got stuff in
there that you got to talk to talk about
is that fair or am i crazy
no that's probably fair okay
so here's the thing you have a more
connected relationship
than probably anyone i've ever heard of
you're the first person i
i have ever heard that in my life
that would have told their wife what
kind of dreams you're having okay
so i want a high five to you and high
five to your wife awesome awesome
awesome
that's a great foundation to start from
i also think you've got some demons in
there you've got some conversations you
need to have with yourself with your
past with your
with your legacy with your heritage
there
it's worth going to spend some time with
a counselor okay especially if you're
going to take on a job where your job is
to care for other people
the third thing is man i want you to try
this i want you to sit
down tonight by yourself you're not
going to show this to anybody
i want you to rewrite this script
rewrite it
and then for the next week i want you to
fold this piece of paper up put in your
pocket and go through it a few times a
day
i show up at my house i walk in my
mother-in-law's there
i say hey i'll see you later you turn
around get back in your car and you
drive away
and then a couple hours later pull that
piece of paper out when you think about
it
read through this script make a mental
picture if you walk in the house you
trying to walk away
and do that several times do that
several times do that several times and
then
when you have if the dream goes away
great dr joyner is the smartest guy ever
and um you're healed and i'm gonna i'm
probably gonna just
start a dream show after that if not
um then you're right back where you
started you don't lose anything right
um and then you can have something else
to talk about with your counselor
but man that's a big deal it's a
it's a big deal and here's the thing you
said it best at the beginning and i want
to make sure everybody hears this
number one when it comes to dreams don't
ever feel
embarrassed or secretive or weird maybe
in this case
right i was going to say never have
secrets i mean
if you're dreaming about your
mother-in-law your father-in-law maybe
hang on to that one yourself
maybe you don't bring that home and just
be like hey everybody
i would probably say in my house i'm
having some really disturbing dreams
that i don't want to talk about but
they're really making me uncomfortable
and um i may go talk to somebody about
it because they keep showing up and
they're happening every other week every
other week every other week
if you're one of the most common things
i i hear is
hey my wife had a
a dream an intimate dream about an old
boyfriend or
had an intimate dream about somebody at
work or something man
be as hard as it's gonna be be curious
not judgmental
right that doesn't mean she wants to
cheat on you that doesn't mean she's
dreaming about her ex boy i mean she's
literally screaming about her
ex-boyfriend but that doesn't mean that
she's pining away for her ex-boyfriend
right
and vice versa it's almost never about
that person
right but sitting on them creates
secrets which create division which
creates
then you find out that you are way far
apart from one another way down
um opposite roads
but man hey i want you to joseph i want
you to try this
and let me know how it goes um man we'll
be
i'll be thinking about this one for a
minute man all right let's uh let's take
one more call let's go to vanessa in
orlando
vanessa what's up hi dr john
what's up um so i
am going to be 37 this year
and i don't really have any
friends and i don't know how to make
friends
oh that sucks doesn't it
it really does i hate that for you are
you new to town
tell me about not having any friends
well i um
i'm just i don't know i'm shy and i'm
awkward and
um hey me too i am too
hey listen i was walking into the
building today
and there was two people that i work
with they're awesome
they're awesome and instead of saying
hey what's up you know what i did
i went i made some weird like
noise and i just stopped in the parking
lot and i was like
i i just made that so weird
unnecessarily
i should have just said hey what's up
guys like a normal per
i remember in college my friend mitch
showed up and i ran over to
i still anyway i'm awkward and shy too
it's good to meet another one of you you
made my heart feel a little bit better
today all right so
you are i just made this all about me
sorry vanessa i just had a
almost like had a confession this is not
a fish okay so
you are awkward and weird in how long
have you not had friends
the majority of my life okay tell me
tell me when you remember not having
friends
um it was in 1991
i was you know you remember the date
i do it was very traumatic um yeah
it's okay we moved from
my nice stable environment to a very
nice
not nice unstable environment
we moved to a village
it was literally a village the
population was 100.
and how old were you when you moved
i believe i was at six oh man yikes
and you know my my parents had recently
got divorced
my mom started dating somebody else and
they just kind of uprooted us
and shifted us away
um so everything in my life everything
in my life changed i had to start taking
a school bus
i had to go to a new school new teachers
no friends
nothing and um it sounds really silly
but i was the
only kid in the school that had red hair
hey hey vanessa vanessa listen
that's not silly at all kids are
evil to each other and every little kid
is walking around insecure
and so they lean on differences they
lean on the sore thumb sticking out they
lean on the new kid they lean on the
redhead kid they lean on the
the no-haired kid they lean on whatever
right
there is nothing weird about that and
you layer
that challenge right being the only
redhead kid
with being the tall girl or the short
girl or the pudgy girl you label that on
top of
parents divorce on top of hey
everything's good all of a sudden
everything's ripped out
man you've got a lifelong thing that a
recede that was planted at six that is
still
growing strong at 37 right yes
so listen do not please i'm not telling
you what to do you're a grown-up
i'm just asking you as a neighbor don't
minimize that that sucks and i hate that
okay that's hard so fast forward through
middle school and high school
sometimes the awkward kids pair off and
make friends with awkward kids that's
what i did i
had awkward friends that played music
together and awkward friends that
i i was a good athlete so we got to hang
out with you know the
the cool kids and but that awkward kids
lived on my street i mean i
i was just felt like i was surrounded by
cool fun awesome also awkward kids i
think in retrospect every kid in high
school is awkward but
um did you you sounds like you navigated
your way through middle school in high
school
just pretty much alone um
up until high school like i didn't
really have um any friends
until 10th grade um and then
a couple you know fellow weirdos kind of
took me under their wing and
that was awesome but after high school
everybody
just kind of scattered and we all
lost touch with each other and um i
actually
grew up in canada and then
i married an american and we moved
you know down to the states and so you
know kind of started fresh
started over didn't know anybody never
really fit in with anybody down here
or up there because i'm in florida now
we were in
indiana and then when we got divorced
i packed up and i was like tired of the
winter i'm tired of the cold
i'm going to florida hey vanessa why did
you
why why'd your marriage not work out
um there was a lot of reasons but the
the main reason was that my my
ex-husband
um convinced me to have an abortion
that i didn't want to do he gave me an
ultimatum
you know i choose the baby and the
streets or i
choose him and our home
[Music]
and you chose the baby and still ended
up out of that home
no um i didn't i i had the abortion
and it was incredibly traumatizing
is the worst experience in my life i've
ever been through
and i just really disconnected after
that because i got no support from him
whatsoever and things just deteriorated
after that
so what do you do for a living now i am
a pet stylist sweet
okay so you're in a job where people
are eccentric and they bring you their
eccentric
pets and tastes and loves and
all that so you just meet people on a
regular basis and you interact with
their pets on a regular basis right
i do um i actually just quit my job
about
two weeks ago to start my own business
okay um so i you know i have
a lot of people that i know um just
nobody that i'm really close to gotcha
so just in your retelling of this to me
do you hear
just the roller coaster of trauma that's
woven its way through your life
oh absolutely and what
what the gasoline the coal that keeps
that roller
coaster riding strong is
shame and worth an
unworthiness yes i'm a failure i screwed
up and i'll always screw up
yes and i failed myself i feel people
around me i'm awkward and you come up
with these narratives like
i'm awkward i'm a little bit weird but
the reality is
you don't like you is that fair that's
100 accurate
okay and so the longer you live in
worlds of secrecy
the longer you live in worlds of i suck
i am not worth liking then
people aren't going to race to
be in community with you right okay
and i don't think you don't have friends
because you're awkward because i'm
real awkward and i have some really
great friends um
i'm really awkward and um
here's the thing you are going to have
to
believe in yourself that you're worth
having friends
and then you're going to have to do the
hardest thing you're ever going to have
to do in your life
at this stage in your life moving
forward and that is to once again
risk and all
friendships all relationships are a risk
yeah i'm going to put it out there and
will they show up
and if they do show up am i gonna screw
it up and you have a two-fold risk
are they gonna show up and are you gonna
screw it up
right right most people have a hard
enough time with
with the first part of that risk
equation or they can even come
right and i want you to know you're not
the dumbest thing you've ever done
you're not your parent's divorce you're
not your parents uprooting you you're
not your red hair as a child you're not
the the deepest shame you carry around
you're not and
you've got to believe i'm worth being
friends with
i'm worth bri i'm gonna bring things
of value to other people and the things
i'm gonna bring are not utilitarian
they're not my cooking or my laughter
they're you
you are the benefit to other people
right
okay yeah and just it's
it's hard because it's super hard have
you dealt with these traumas
um no um actually um from
listening to to your podcast i've
actually because i was in
um after i moved down to florida i was
in an abusive
relationship with a narcissist and i
started going to
talk therapy and um you know i got my
life a little bit back on track and then
got out of that relationship
and then my life totally exploded
and i ended up homeless and the past
four years i've just kind of been trying
to get back up on my feet
and now that i'm back up on my feet i
am back in counseling awesome
so when you project to the world i have
no value
i'm a loser i'm the worst thing i ever
did i'm not accountable to even to
myself
there is a kind of person who's
attracted to that and that is somebody
who will use you
abuse you you will become an end to
their means
right right i'm sorry you'll become a
means to their end
and that's how those cycles continue and
then you find yourself in an abusive
relationship
and somebody hurts you and instead of
them getting their
um owning the weight of their evil
the shame cycle continues right because
that's what shame does it it
it beats up its owner right absolutely
so you're doing the right thing going to
counseling
tells you that you're worth spending the
money that you're worth the time
getting a job that you feel good about
where you have good talents
where you show up every day where you do
good
work or you help people with their pets
or their lives or their
their friends or whatever that's going
to help you
be a person of value and then this is
gonna sound
weird and we have completely abandoned
this in our culture and so we literally
have to learn it
you're gonna have to learn some skills
uh on
friendship you're gonna have to practice
being a friend
and that sounds ridiculous because that
seems like the
easiest thing in the world to know how
to do right
like yeah because when your kids you
just all
get together we had some people over the
other night and
i don't even know what they were doing i
just know my daughter comes running out
of the house in a frozen dress with a
bow and arrow
and my son i don't know what was
happening but they just created a game
out of nothing and there was all
different age ranges they were just
in it right right when you're 37 you
can't do that
right if you show up to a local pub
wearing a frozen dress and a bow and
arrow they're probably going to call
somebody right
probably and so you have to practice
skills
what does that mean here's a good
example i just made a weird
howling wolfy noise in a parking lot and
i had to stop
and say hey i just made that super
awkward i'm
i'm sorry and one of the guys knows me
well his name's brad he's awesome
he's like so lovely and he said hey man
just keep being you
and that was them saying we know you're
weird and we love you anyway
right there are those people
and you are going to make awkward jokes
you're going to be talking to someone
and
someone's going to say something that's
going to remind you of your childhood
it's going to remind you of the
pregnancy
that you lost it's going to remind you
of an abusive ex and your heart's going
to take over it's gonna start racing
you're gonna have
you're gonna be anxious anxious anxious
and you're gonna get up and walk out
and that's when you text him and you say
hey i'm sorry i walked out on you
i totally had some bad memories my bad i
will never do that again let's circle
back up next week
and that's what i mean by practicing how
do you sit there and with your counselor
i want you to tell your counselor hey
counselor
i want to practice relationship skills i
want to practice
being a good friend and your counselor
if they're worth
one quarter of what you're paying them
will be able to teach you some of those
things
and then you're gonna be able to project
value to the world
because you're gonna have the skill set
to be a good friend
and again this is not utilitarian this
is not oh she's the one we call when we
need it nope
this is just i'm vanessa i'm worth being
friends with
and by the way vanessa you've had a a
traumatic history let's make no doubt
about it right you know that i know that
all of our listeners know that but i
don't want you to feel like
you're by yourself because i know people
who are
deathly lonely in a crowded space with a
family and a couple of kids
i know people who are lonely who just
lost a loved one and don't even know
they don't even know what day it is
right because they're grieving so hard
there are millions and millions of
people who are
lonely lonely lonely and i want
everyone to start risking
friendship start going out there and
saying hey
i'm lonely i know you're lonely let's go
get a drink let's go get some pizza
that's going to give us
gas and make us not sleep well let's go
do so let's go kick a soccer ball let's
do a thing let's go for a walk whatever
i have a good friend named cassie i
learned so much about hospitality from
her you know why
she just kept having potlucks at her
house her and her husband gordon they're
incredible
just kept inviting people over and they
were awkward conversations there were
people that were like didn't get along
at work but suddenly showed up at her
house
and you know what she just kept doing it
and she was so lovely and we were always
greeted with a hug and we always had
good conversations and played games and
talked about literature and law and
weird stuff
and i thought oh my gosh this is what
friendship looks like
this is what showing up and showing up
and showing up and showing up
she just kept going first she just kept
going first she just kept going first
and my wife and i learned what
hospitality learned what friendship
looked like from her
and be curious not judgmental
right say yes be safe right you got a
trauma history be safe but say yes be
open for adventures
but vanessa at the at the at the very
bottom here you've got to know you're
not the worst things that have happened
to you
you're worth being loved you're worth
being well and you're worth being in a
relationship with other people
i'm proud of you because i know going to
counseling is hard
i'm proud of you for wanting to strike
out on your own but i want you get a job
where you're making some real money
right and you got to go to work every
day you need some structure right now
and i want you to be bold and direct
with that counselor and say i want to
learn some skills on how to connect with
people
because what you need is relationships
and what's hurt you has been
relationships
so you've got some healing and some
learning to do in there i'm
so so grateful you called vanessa i i
need you to know that you just helped a
lot of people
you helped a lot of people being
vulnerable and telling about your story
all right so as we wrap up today's show
oh
let's see here you know what we're gonna
go old school
i was gonna go 1995. nope we're gonna go
to 1976.
and there's some debate here i know
there's some debate i'm just gonna say
man these are the pinnacle
johnny joey the ramones
in 1976 dropped their self-titled album
hey james i was about to start reading
this but it sounds different when i'm
reading it
if i just read hey ho let's go i know it
sounds bad
but that's not what i mean so you gotta
listen to the song context is everything
context is everything
my dad used to tell me that as a kid so
i know it sounds bad if you've never
heard this song but that's not how
that's not what it means it's just h-o
it's just h-o
hey-o let's go like that
and then it continues they're forming in
a straight line
they're going through a tight wind the
kids are losing their minds
blitzkrieg bop they're piling in the
backseat their generation steam heat i
don't even know what that means steam
heat that sounds gross
pulsating to the back seat blitzkrieg
bop
oh let's go what they want i don't know
they're all revved up and ready to go
they're forming in a straight line
they're going through a tight win the
kids are losing their
mind blitzkrieg but i don't even know
what this song is about
i hope it's good but they're all revved
up and ready to go
thank you for joining us right here on
the dr john dolone show
you